as the veteran left-hander is on the
mound 41 years old
rich hill starting for the bench this
evening hasn't gone more than five
innings rudy's had one good outing with
the mets that was against the marlins
vic curveball you know and he needs to
come up aces today here's the 2-2 to him
swung out and missed strike three hill
with a fastball and that's only an 88
mile an hour fastball
but he elevated it up and in and robles
down on strike so one away
the line and the one-hole delivery swung
on and ripped to left on a line to base
it toward the line dominic smith over to
get it escobar will make the turn and
he'll hold it first with a one-out
single stretching a hitting streak to
nine games in a row now for el cities
escobar that's 12 hits breaking ball
pulled on the ground to third backhanded
along the line by davis long throw to
first right there plenty of time to get
bell and that retires the side no runs a
hit and one man left now the mets will
face the 34 year old right-hander who
was born in panama but went to high
school in bradenton florida by the name
of paulo espino they have seen him
before but he is certainly testament
espino is to perseverance
and the breaking ball is going to fool
him
two down paulo espino 59 strikeout in 76
innings one odel endorsed we're going to
drive to the gap in right center pretty
deep headed towards the warning track
over comes roblox he can't get it
bounces behind him picked up on the
track by soto lindor around second going
to third the relay throw head first
slide he's safe a triple francisco
lindor with a three base hit
and that is a mets rarity here's the
pitch
swing and a miss he threw a beauty that
one started like it was going to be over
the plate and then darted down and away
and bias swung over
two up two down and riley adams will be
the better he's the catcher
he waited for the breaking ball and
hammered it to left center and it's on
the ground deflects off brandon nimmo
dominic smith will cover it up two out
double riley adams
now 11 for his last 23. oh two to garcia
swung on him missed strike three got him
with a curved side retired and so in the
end on that double by adams
no harm no foul i guess a hit one left
middle of the second here's jd davis 2-2
with one out espino delivers swinging a
mess breaking ball he strikes out davis
for the second out here in the bottom of
the second third strikeout for paolo
espino here's the wine of the o2
swinging a fly ball
left field toward the corner moving over
the left fielder thomas has room
and he makes the catch for the out
so we finally found the left fielder
underneath it
now the mets are in trouble base is
loaded nobody out here comes juan soda
sidearm breaking ball ground ball right
side alonzo has it he looks at home but
instead takes the out at first
so it's an rbi for soto scoring the
pitcher espino and the nationals lead
one nothing
and the infield's back here it's all
josh bell has to do is hit a ground ball
of the short and it's two nothing
and he will strike one out into left row
blaze scores and the nationals lead two
to nothing so bell matches soto with his
70th rbi and the nationals keep the line
moving here in the third sidearm
delivery and he struck him out with the
slider
so there's the second out for hill his
third strike out of the night as he gets
kibum and the curve ball foul tip and
nito held it for strike three
there's a king size out for rich hill
two-nothing as washington has the lead
riley adams will lead off the top of the
fourth two two coming to adams and he
struck him out with a high fastball five
strikeouts now for hill including his
last three batters
strikes out of spino
and that's six strikeouts now for hill
two out of the inning yeah spino wasn't
gonna get any more fastballs oh two
pitch swing and a miss strike three rich
hill with five strikeouts in the last
two innings he gets all three outs in
this inning with strikeouts javi baez
next who struck out with lindor at third
ending the first inning bias it's a high
fly right center field it's deep sodo's
back near the wall hooking up it's gone
home run to the opposite field for
javier baez and the mets are on the
board it's now a two to one washington
league espino's delivery
swinging a miss on a curve in the dirt
ball picked up by adams he'll step out
in front of the plate throw down to bell
to complete the strikeout
and make it official fourth k
for paulo espino as he makes quick work
of conforto on three pitches he was
badly full
espino's one-two
check swing strike three could not hold
him a slider off the plate and so espino
gets back-to-back strikeouts after his
mistake [ __ ] homer here's the one-two
pitch
swung on and missed strike three got him
with a fastball and rich hill now has
eight strikeouts one two to bell hit
hard on the ground the other way but one
big hop for baez he's got it throws to
first in time side retired so rich hill
very effective through five innings for
the first time tonight he gets the side
in order to go to the last of the fifth
inning mitchell have the bottom third of
their order due up
he wasn't looking for that was he
right in there three k's in a row six
for paolo espinosa i threw them pretty
much all curveballs there and snuck the
fastball in their 3-2 and it locked them
up
no way to make contact with that baby
and there's a new career high for paolo
number seven breaking ball struck him
out
there castro will pitch the seventh
inning for new york yeah 54th appearance
for mcgill harrah's running
throwing from his knees as neato and a
hop is with the tag but too late bias
thinks he got him though
baez is so quick with those tags and it
might have fooled the second base umpire
rob drake he felt as though he got para
and the mets are going to challenge the
call
he's out they're going to call him out
so the throw by neato and the incredible
tagging skills of javi baez white
gerardo paro off the base they call him
el mago and there's a reason 3-2 pitch
swinging a miss strike three nasty
slider from castro awkward swing from
escobar the inning is over no runs no
hits as juan soto will lead things off
for washington
and he takes strike three call 99 mile
an hour four-seam fastball from jerry's
familia
and soto goes away shaking his head he
had a three-and-oh advantage and familia
threw him three straight strikes
and now a third and
again uses the four-seamer to get the
strikeout did it on soto this time he
came upstairs to bell so jay reese with
back-to-back strikeouts that is 13
strikeouts for met pitchers tonight wow
that is just uh not a good at bat right
there now the pitch to kibu
swung on and missed strike three got him
with a slider down and away and jerry's
familia strikes out the side in the
eighth inning
now finnegan on to try and save it for
washington tying man aboard to begin the
bottom of the ninth inning and the 1-1
pitch swing the ground ball scrolling
garcia has it he dribbles the ball to
second to escobar for the force on
alonso
and the out at second base one away
he holds he kicks the pitch swinging the
ground ball chop toward the middle
garcia has it he steps on second he
throws to first and a curly w is in the
books
and the nationals storm out of the
dugout they take game one of the series
in the big apple as they hand the mets
their fourth loss in a row and 12th in
the last 14 games
you